President Paul Kagame: Thank you, Provost
Alan Brinkley, and my good friend
Josh, for those kind words of introduction,
and thank you for inviting me to
participate in the World Leaders Forum
this year. Distinguished ladies and
gentlemen, let me say at the outset that
it is my distinct pleasure to address this
august audience of this prestigious University.
I am told that Columbia University
is the fifth oldest institution of higher
learning in the United States, and that you
are committed to preserving the quest
for knowledge as more than simply a
practical pursuit.
Judging from the number of leading minds
that are part of the community of
Columbia University, I am persuaded to
concur with one of your alumni who said
that "the best things of all human history
and thought are inside the rectangle of
Columbia University." And so, it is indeed
a privilege for me to address you on
the them of the Millennium Development
Goals from Rwanda's perspective.
Distinguished Ladies and Gentlemen, as
you know, five years ago the world's
leaders met and launched the Millennium
Development Goals.
They made a solemn pledge to work together
to end extreme poverty and
hunger, promote human dignity, to achieve
peace, democracy, and
environmental sustainability by 2015 or
earlier. This was reaffirmed at the
Monterrey Conference on Financing for
Development in March 2002, and at the
Johannesburg World Summit on Sustainable
Development in September 2002.
And in 2004 your very own Prof. Jeffrey
Sachs led a global team that rolled out a
practical plan to achieve the goals.
At the time of the Millennium Summit,
the targets for the Millennium Development
Goals were judged to be attainable, given
the amount of wealth and global
abundance, as well as what Prof. Sachs
has ably referred to as the greatest
technological and scientific explosion
of knowledge. And yet, despite this
unprecedented creation of wealth and knowledge,
there are still frightening levels
of poverty for the majority of the world's
populations, and many in the developing
world continue to die of deprivation,
hunger, malnutrition, preventable diseases,
and endless conflicts.
It is, in my view, unacceptable that today,
according to UN statistics, 345 million
Sub-Sahara Africans live in poverty. In
some Sub-Sahara African countries, as
many as 70 percent of the region's population
live on less than one dollar a day.
228 million Sub-Sahara Africans suffer
from undernourishment and 4.7 million
children die each year of hunger and disease.
That is an average of nearly 13,000 every
day or 500 children dying every hour.
Similarly, 280 million people in Sub-Sahara
Africa have no access to clean and
safe drinking water and 167 million live
in slum conditions. Now, these statistics
say it all. We need no further statistics
to show us that at this rate, Africa is not
exactly on track to meet the Millennium
Development Goals. In fact, in some
targets like poverty, GDP per capita and
undernourishment, there will be a
regression in the situation between now
and 2015, if left to business as usual.\
Some have of course argued that there
is no one else to blame, and I agree that
we Africans must take first responsibility
for this sorry state of affairs on our
continent. But that is not to deny the
fact that in this increasingly shrinking world,
or global village, as it has been referred
to, all nations are interdependent,
whether they are big or small, rich or
poor.
And also that a world where the majority
live in such a sorry state, on less than
one dollar a day, amidst the highest recorded
global productivity and
concentration of wealth, is an unsafe
world. In fact, such a world is dangerously
prone to manipulations by those whose
interest in violence, international
terrorism, and genocide preys on the hopelessness
of the deprived.
Equally, we must acknowledge that this
interdependence engenders shared
responsibilities and obligations, which
undoubtedly include the imperative for
development and attainment of the Millennium
Development Goals. We must
collectively agree that development is
liberation from want and from fear, so that
all peoples can live dignified lives.
All peoples, not some. But judging from the
status of play in Sub-Sahara Africa, as
I have just outlined, the picture is not
promising unless we devise, together with
our development partners, and agree
to faithfully implement innovative and
practicable measures that can reverse the
current trends.
In Rwanda we recognize the importance
of the Millennium Development Goals,
and we see them as prerequisites and the
roadmap for the realization of our own
Vision 2020, the blueprint for our socio-economic
development. Besides, their
targets are imbedded in our Poverty Reduction
Strategy, a program of economic
growth, in place since 2000, that aims
to generate wealth and increase choices
for the poor.
So, clearly, we are determined to do our
bit, and although there are still
bottlenecks, we seem to be making significant
progress. For instance, in Goal
Number 2, we have introduced universal
primary education, and as a result, we
have attained over 90 percent primary
one enrollment, and net enrollment in
primary schools of 82 percent.
We have striven to promote gender equality
in all sectors of Rwandan life and we
have attained the 50:50 enrollment of
girls and boy children in primary education,
contained in the Millennium Development
Goal Number Three. As for gender
equality in decision making organs, we
now have a ratio of 49 percent women in
parliament and 35 percent in the Cabinet.
We are, I think, to a great extent on
track in the areas of gender parity and
universal primary education.
That said, I wish I could be as optimistic
for the other goals. We are doing our
best, but like other African countries,
there is no way we can achieve the
Millennium Development Goals without a
true partnership at the local, national,
and between developed and developing countries,
based on our shared
commitment and determination to promote
economic and social advancement of
all peoples.
This will necessitate on the part of our
development partners three cardinal
things in development financing: first,
improvement in the quality and quantity of
official development assistance (ODA);
second, fairer trade; and Third, debt
cancellation, which several countries
in Africa, including Rwanda, are now
benefiting from. The quality of official
development assistance should be
improved by adopting needs-based approaches,
providing more budget support,
supporting and harmonizing with national
poverty reduction programs, reducing
waste and overheads, and by channeling
aid to sectors that enhance productive
capacities rather than those that perpetuate
dependency.
There should also be greater consultation,
coordination, harmonization, and
policy coherence among official development
assistance recipients and donors.
Effective official development assistance
should be untied to procurement of
over-priced equipment and consultants
from donor countries. All these proposals
are contained in both the Monterrey Consensus
as well as the Paris Declaration
on aid effectiveness, which must be implemented.
Distinguished audience, the
global commitment to achieve the Millennium
Development Goals in the next ten
years requires massive mobilization of
financial resources and their immediate
deployment for immediate employment.
We welcome the decision by some developed
countries to substantially increase
their volume of official development assistance
over the last few years. We also
congratulate those states that have reached
or exceeded the internationally
agreed 0.7 percent of GNI for official
development assistance target and
welcome the decision by those states that
have set timetables to achieve or
exceed that target by the year of 2015.
These commitments should significantly
improve the prospects of many
developing countries to attain the Millennium
Development Goals. But for these
resources to be effective in the attainment
of the Millennium Development Goals,
their disbursement should be accelerated,
flexible, and predictably available for
implementation. Fairer trade will entail
recommitting ourselves, both in principle
and practice, to an open, rule-based,
non-discriminatory, and equitable
multilateral trading system.
Any progress that developing countries
like Rwanda might achieve in attaining
the Millennium Development Goals will
not be sustainable unless measures are
taken, at the same time, to provide a
greater opportunity to access the richer
markets of the developed world and, thereby,
increase household and national
incomes. In this regard, we welcome and
support the proposal for duty-free and
quota-free market access for all exports
from Least Developed Countries to the
markets of developed countries, as well
as the proposal to ease supply side
constraints and commodity price shocks
in Least Developed Countries to enable
them take the fullest possible advantage
of increased market access.
All our eyes are set on the successful
completion of the WTO Doha round of
multilateral trade negotiations in 2006
and implementation of the Doha
Development Agenda, paying due regard
to agricultural trade issues,
liberalization of trade in services, and
the promotion of export competitiveness.
The recent decision to cancel the debt
of 18 highly indebted least developed
African countries is a very commendable
manifestation of the commitment by
those countries to the development of
least developed countries.
Rwanda is one of the 18 countries that
qualified for debt cancellation. Our debt
once stood at US dollars 1.2 billion whose
annual servicing at the time was 523
percent of exports earnings. Cancellation
of our debt means that the
Government can now channel nearly 40 million
US dollars, which it previously
spent annually on debt servicing, towards
improving or expanding social service
delivery around the country.\
The challenge now is to access sufficient
grant-based development financing that
will prevent the reversal of our debt
sustainability while providing the needed
investment for economic growth and poverty
reduction. Ladies and gentlemen, it
is clear to us that attainment of the
Millennium Development Goals is also
contingent on good political and economic
governance. In Rwanda, we have
implemented several political and economic
reforms over the last decade,
including democratization and decentralization
of the central and local
governments.
We have put in place institutions that
promote accountability and transparency,
and we have introduced measures that combat
corruption and abuse of public
office. We have also implemented a series
of measures to ensure fiscal
discipline, to eliminate waste in the
public sector, while also boosting trade and
inward investment. We will continue to
do what it takes in this process,
particularly in the area of good political,
economic, and corporate governance.\
May I add that while we view improvements
in governance as a continuum and a
dynamic process rather than a static end
goal, we believe that we have made
significant progress, which gives us reason
to be optimistic that with enhanced
support of our development partners, we
could attain the Millennium
Development Goal targets by 2015. Distinguished
ladies and gentlemen, let me
conclude by reiterating that the socio-economic
development of our countries
and the emancipation of our people is
primarily our responsibility.
But the Millennium Development Goals are
a compact between rich and poor,
and rich countries must honor their commitments
and fulfill the obligations that
accompany these commitments. I am pleased
to assure you that for Rwanda,
the will and enthusiasm for achieving
the MDGs is there. What remains to be
seen is the same commitment on the part
of our development partners.
We believe that we cannot afford to miss
this opportunity that has the potential to
change the welfare of so many in the world.
But while we dither and prevaricate,
children continue to die of starvation
and preventable diseases. Others go to bed
and fail to sleep because they are hungry.
This is not the kind of world we want
to bequeath to generations to come in
this new Millennium. I wish to say thank
you for your kind attention and I will
appreciate your questions and comments.